ないんです これは数えられないほど業があるんだけど
大目に見たってもう七つやってるんです
業 だから七回結果を受けるんです
一回の業したら結果は七倍になっちゃう
七回になるんです 七倍ではなくて
もっとたくさんですけど
その七回の業で一回目の即病心の業は今世で結果出す
七番目は次の生で結果を出す
でもいつでもそれ不可能なんです
我々やってるいいことを全部今世で結果が出るかといえば出ないんです
例えばいいことをしたっても
妨害業働いていると なかなかもう機能しないんです
ですから このほとんどのこの一回目の業が消えちゃう
結果出せなくなる それにも阿呆しカルマというんです
消えるカルマ そこで二回
七番も同じなんですね
七番目の業も それもこの次の生まれだから
確実に結果出すっていうことじゃないんで
ほとんど重い業か あの
慣れてる業か あるいは一番最近死の間際にやった業か
どっちか結果出しますから
このやってることほとんどもう消えちゃうんです
ですから ほとんどの我々にもいつでもあるんです
この消える業が 厳密に言えば
ほとんどこの一番目と七番目は消えちゃうんですね
だからこの今世で結果出せなかったら
このカルマのエネルギーは終わり
この心からそのエネルギーは消えちゃうんです
あまりインパクトはないんです
二から六のインパクトは残っちゃうんです
それで誰にでも阿呆しカルマという消える業があるんです
普通の人に消える業はほとんど一番目と七番目の即病心の業
で 悟りなんかになっちゃったらもうかなりの量で消えてしまうんですね
もう一つその セットがあったんだけど消えたか
うん もう一つの四種類ありますね
それは簡単で 次の四つは説明しなくてもわかりますと
一番目はアクセラ アクセラ
アクセラっていうのは不善あるいは罪ですね
悪いこと  二番目はカーマーチラクセラ
これはあんまり まあカーマーチラっていうのは欲界の善
欲界の善 で 欲界の善っていうのは欲界
人間も欲界であって 天国も欲界であって
地獄も全部欲界ですけど
地獄に行くのは不善をしたら地獄に行っちゃうし
普通の善はカーマーチラクセラと言うんです
次にルーパーチラ ルーパーチラクセラというのは色界の善ですね
色界というのは人間も神々も超えている次元ですね
梵天の次元 だから梵天の次元に生まれ変われる業をこの言葉で説明しているんです
いわゆる禅定ですね 瞑想してサマーディ作ったら
それにはルーパーチラクセラというんです
それは瞑想のみ 瞑想のサマーディのみ
人に何か施しをしたんだからといって
ルーパーチャラ・プサラにはならないんです
病院作ったんだとと言っても
一人の人が自分の財産
個人の財産を全部使って増やして病院一個作ったんだと
それで無料で治療しているんだと言っても
それはカーマーチャラ・プサラ
欲界の善です 色界になるためには瞑想しかない
瞑想してサマーディ作るしかない
それ同じくアルーパ・アーチャラ
これはさらに難しくて
無色界ですね で サマーディをさらに瞑想してね
あの無色界の４つの次元がありますから
その線ではここでそのカテゴリーで分けて
強引に四つに分けただけですけど
それは次元ですね カルマの
我々知っている三次元はこちら三次元とは言いませんだけど
我々知っているのはこのアクサラとカーマーチャラ・アクサラなんですね
人間が善というのは嘘を言わないとかね
人を助けてあげるとか
施しをするとか 優しくするとか
隣人を愛するとか それぐらいのものなんです
そういうのは全部欲界の善なんです
それほど次元高いわけじゃないんです
人を助けるとか まあいろいろあることはあるんだけど
全部欲界の善で まあせいぜい天国には行けます
それ以上は行けません
それよりも瞑想することは随分次元が違う
瞑想して心を清らかにするということで
もう一番最低のレベルで成功したっても
ルーパ・アーチャラ次元には行っちゃうんだから
次元が変わる だから心を整えることは一番善の中でレベル高い善で
善行為です 世俗的にみんな喜ぶ徳行はいくらまとめたっても瞑想には敵わない
何か問題ある？ いいですか？聞いて
今日の授業聞いてると現象の世界の話みたいな
現象世界というか 実際に起こる出来事でカルマする視点で見るんですけど
テキスト読んでるとテキストを読むと
サラ・シュタ サラ・シュタからヴィパッサナーの方が意識が生まれるって説明があったりするんですけど
心のなんか心のなんかのシステムで説明してるような風にテキストを読むと見えるんですけど
それは  これは五でしょ
五サラ クサラチッタでしょ
熟心じゃないんです だから業というと両方業なんです
あのクサラチッタ アクサラチッタとイジュクシンという 3つも業です
業というと全部入ってるんです
ですから今の説明 全部ごちゃ混ぜてるんです
例えばディッタダンウェーディニヤというのはイジュクシンでしょ
この場合はもうイジュクシンだけで説明すればそれはそれで構いませんし
一般的に業という業とイジュグ
両方まとめて業というでしょうね
ここで行為をする そちらの結果を受けると
両方両方と言うんです
ですからカンマ カンマ
リパーカという言葉は 2つあります
カンマっていうのはこの善心不善心ですね
次にカンマリパーカと書いてあるんです
イジュクシンというのはリパーカですね
だからこの両方まとめて一般的にはカンマと言うんです
両方に 私の説明ではこの全部この両方まとめて一般的に説明してたんです
で 誰でも気になるのはイジュクなん
結果なんですね 行為よりは
ですから 結果の方に重点を入れてるんです
いつ結果出るか どのように結果が出るかと
結果が出なきゃ別に気にする必要ないんだからね
どうせ結果は問題ですから
でも結果は行為の結果だからね
ですから このアクサラっていうのは
地獄 4種類ありますしね
そちらに生まれる行為はアクサラという
人間の世界と天界に生まれる行為はカーマーヴァチラクサラと言うんですね
結果論で言うならば 分定期に生まれる業にはルーパヴァチラクサラと言うんですね
無色界の分定期に生まれる業にはルーパヴァチラクサラと言うんです
どっちでもこのこのコンセプトでやる行為ですからね
じゃあ 次の読みだけでわかると思います
この 148 ページに カーマーヴァチラアクサラカンマ
3つ書いてます で カーマーヴァチラアクサラカンマ
これアクサラカンマ  3つあるんだと
3つっていうのは体でする行為と言葉でする行為と
意で考える行為と 身口意ですね
そこら辺は一応覚えておいてください
こちらの このカーマーヴァチラという言葉はこちらにも当てはまります
カーマーヴァチラアクサラ
カーマーヴァチラクサラと読まなくちゃいけないんです
そこでカーマーヴァチラアクサラ言わなくたってアクサラは全部もうカーマーヴァチラなんです
欲界なんです で 不善はどれくらいあるか
何種類かというと 3種類ですよと
体でする行為 言葉でする行為
考えて考えること それも行為です
で なぜわざとそう言いますかというと
俗世間では 一般の社会では体だけすることはすごいと思ってるし
言葉のことはそんなに重くは思ってない
考えることは自由だと思ってるんだけど
仏教は逆に思ってるんですね
考えることは一番重い罪だと
それより喋ることは軽いんだと
それよりも行動は軽いんだと
それは仏教の順番 なんでそうなるんですかというと
結局考えなきゃ喋れないんですね
考えなきゃ行動もできないし
言葉自体は考え方がないと別に大したことないんです
言葉は本当にひどくなるか
ひどい結果になるか 悪い結果になるかというのは考え方次第でしょうし
人のことは全然怒ってもないし
その人のことをすごく可愛いと思っているし
可愛いと思っていて お前本当に憎たらしいやつだと
見たくもないんですよ
ああいうこと言ったって全然悪口にならないんですね
聞いてる相手も全然平気で聞いているんです
でも気持ちとしても その人が嫌だなと思ったら
その言葉違うんです その時は
その時の言葉のエフェクトは違うんです
だから人に全然バカだと思わないで
ただ可愛いんだからあんたバカですねとか言っても
聞いてる側は全然気にしない
バカと思って言ったら
それ結果が随分違う ですから
考え方はいつでも裏にあるんですね
そういうことで一番メインポイントは考え方なんです
そこでこの社会問題が出てくるので
たまたま 今はこの犯罪は低年齢化しているんだとかね
なぜ小学生がいろんなことをやってるんだ
中学生とかね その行為だけ見ているんですね
でも ナイフを持って人を刺す子供が突然そうなって人を刺したわけじゃないんです
ただ面白いもんだから刺したよとかね
そんなことにはならない
それ人を刺すまで この子はいろんなことを考えてきたんですね
それの結果ですから だからそういう社会問題なんかを直す場合は
一番この思考を直すということはいつでも大事なんです
何考えてるんですかと
なぜそういう風に考えてるんですかと
そこら辺何とかしなくちゃいけないんです
なんかテレビで見たんだけど
なんか子供たちはしゃべれないんだと
先生ともしゃべれない
両親ともしゃべれない
そこは一つ問題だと 私もそうだと思います
いろんな意見あるんでしょうけど
それは人に喋れないと
これすごい問題なんですね
いわゆる言いたいことはあるんだけど
言えない環境を作っているんですね
だから言えない場合は
これ直せないでしょうね
例えば子供が乱暴な言葉を使ったんだと
平気で使ったならば 親にそれを直せるんですね
あんた そういう風に言葉を使ってはいけません
二度と使ったらもうただじゃおきませんよとか
脅すことでも何でもできるんです
使ったならば そこで母親に向かって全然そういう言葉使わない
黙っている 黙っているんだから
おとなしい子だとすごい勘違いしちゃうんですね
いろいろあって 心の中でいろんなストレス溜まってる可能性あるんです
ですから 喋れないということは
それまで喋れない環境を親が学校が作っているということなんです
それでもう自分の仲間に入っちゃって
もうやりたいことをやってしまっちゃう
ですから考え方を直すことはすごく大事なんです
人に自分の意見を言える環境を作らなくちゃいけない
自由にね アイデアの交換できる環境とか
それは日本で抑えてるんですね
他の人が違う意見言ったら困るんだと
あまりにも下手なんですね
これはまとめて行動できないんだと
だからみんなロボットみたいに右足上げなさいと言ったら右足を上げてくれればそれでいい
はい 左足上げなさいと言ったら左足上げてくれればそれでいいんだと
それでうまくまとめるんだと言って
それあまりにも誤解なんです
もし一人の子が なんで先生右足上げなくちゃいけないんですか？と言ったら
お前黙っていろと みんなやってるんだからやれ
それだけでしょうに そうするともう聞きたくても聞けなくなっちゃう
反論があっても言えなくなっちゃう
だから大人が自分の都合にもう力弱い人々をみんな抑えてるんですね
政府が国民を抑えている
企業が国民を抑えている
国民もお互いに上下関係で上の人はできるだけしゃべるなとみんな抑えている
それで全然いい結果がないんです
なぜ会社潰れるんですかね
例えば大蔵省の人だって普通の仕事してる人全部知ってるんでしょうし
上の人々がどんなことをやってるんですかと
でもしゃべったら自分も立場がなくなっちゃいますから
もう抑えられちゃって
それでもう悪い結果になるでしょうし
銀行も金融機関も潰れるでしょうし
だからこの学校もいろいろ問題を起こし
家庭の中でも問題を起こしてしまう
ですから 互い自由だから
互い平等だから 人に違う意見を言う権利もあるし
それは意見は間違っていると自分が間違っているということは証明しなくちゃいけないし
それはしちめんどくさくて
我論だけでいこうとする
それで悪いことに 自分の意見だけ通して欲しがる人々に限って
みんな間違ってるんです
みんな病気なんです 人の意見聞きたくない
頭が悪い 自分に人の意見聞いて理解できない
だからそれ全部抑えて黙っていなさい
言う通りになりなさい
すごい態度をとっちゃう
あんな大胆な態度をとるのは
みんな私の立場から言えばみんな失格だと
みんなの意見も聞いて
それだったらこうすればいいでしょうというふうな新しいひらめきがいる人こそ
立派な知識人であって
智慧の人なんですね 人が反対したっても
その人を納得することはできるんだと
だからそういうこのいろんな多次元で問題を考えたりするのはなかなかない
これすごい重要なんですね
すぐに急にできないかもしれません
私もたまたま試しにやってみちゃいますけど
なかなかうまくいかないんですね
自分の国みたいに 自分の国のことなんか
なんかとんでもないへんとか
みんな反論言っちゃえばすぐやられちゃうんです
それにはすぐもうなんとかで答えちゃうんです
だからそれは自分を自分が負けても何か言って
それで決して嫌な気持ちじゃないんです
そこで心の中でこいつは小さい割になかなかやるんだとという気持ちだけなんですね
大人に向かって何ですかと
その言葉というふうに気持ちにならない
私はもう知った覚悟の上で変な変なことを言うんだから
言われたって自分ではもうそれを知ってるし
かえって反論しないと私はすごくもう嫌なんですね
言うことを聞いて 馬鹿みたいに黙って聞いてるんだったら
この連中はもういいと思うな
付き合わなくても 育てられませんだから
だから言うことに まあそう言われたって
もうだってこういうことだからああだこうだですよと何かいちいちうるさく言うと
それ説明することもできるし
こういうことだからやらなくちゃいけない
だからこちらはしっかりしなくちゃいけないし
やる側もちゃんと理解の上でやっちゃうし
まあそういうふうなのが正しいやり方なんですけど
これは仏教から言えばなんですけど
仏教では業はやっぱり一番思考が一番重い業なんです
思考があった上で人は喋ったり行動したりする
だから心が汚れたら行動は汚れるし
喋る言葉も汚れるし 心が清らかだったら全部もう清らかなものに生きてきます
それで次にあるのはこの時間ですね
これすぐ終わります 体の行為は体の罪は何ですかと
体で起こすものは 番目はパーナーディパータ
殺生 番目は浮遊種 アディンナーダーナという
自分のものでないものは他人のものを取る事ですね
自分でないものは自分のものにすること
で 次にはジャヨクゴ 欲に対して間違っている行動ということ
欲といえば これちょっと学者の間でも疑問がありましたけど
私にもよく教えてもらったある先生が教授なんですけど
それは私とも意見が違っていたんだけど
僕はそれでもその先生に賛成しなかったんだけど
で この欲っていうのはゲンミビシシンを楽しめることなんですね
体を楽しめることなんですね
だからそれは悪いと言っているわけじゃないんです
で 体は楽しませてもいいんだけど
ちゃんと決まり守れと
決まりがあるんだ その決まりも破って楽しいんだからいいんじゃないかということは認めない
楽しいんだからいいわけじゃなくて
正しく行動しなさいと
体楽しむことをやめなさいと言ってないんです
それこの教授とこの異論になったところは
この他のところで戒律として説明する場合は
それは不邪淫とかね 例えば不倫とか
そういうことを考えているんですね
で 私はそれだけじゃないんだと
で この誤解させている場合も
今いろんなお坊さんたちが
あのカーメスと言ってそこで止まっちゃうんです
カーメスミッチャチャーラヴェーラマニシッカパダンサマーディア
で そこに止まって解釈するんです
そこ教授にはちょっと気に入らない
その教授にとってはこのカーメスミッチャチャーラっていうのは
自分のお坊さん以外 異性とは楽しむことへ
それは戒律としてハッキリと説明しているんだと
でも今のお坊さんたちが
お坊さんたちはこの教授は在家の人なんですけど
教授の方がもうすごい仏教の教授でも
お坊さんたちよりは知識的には立場はすごいんでしたけど
このお坊さんたちはね
今頃僕に言うんです カーメスと複数形にしているんだと
それは違いますよと そしたら僕は先生そう言うんだけど
カーメカーマとカーマっていうのを経典でどうやって説明しているんですか？と僕は聞くんですね
カーマとっていうのはゲンミビシシンの対象なる色受想行識全部カーマと書いてるでしょうと
私はあのお坊さんたちの説明は正しいと思ってますよと
でもそう言われたって
もうそれだったら我々のは在家の人々に生活ができなくなるんだとかね
で まあそれは違いますけどね
僕は一応説明してのは
そんなもう日常生活を楽しむことは否定してないんだと
そこに決まり守れと 例えば音楽を聴くなではなく
音楽ばっかし聞いて人生台無しにするなと
美しいものを見てもいいんだけど
それにもそれなりの法則があって
その中でやればいいんです
美味しいものを食べてもいいんだけど
それに凝ってしまったらどうなるんですかね
ですから そこら辺も罪だと見た方がより人間が自己コントロールできるんじゃないかと
これ性行為だけ戒律だと言ったところで
みんな性行為さえ悪いことしなきゃいいんだと
そこら辺コントロールするんで
自分の国だったらみんなほとんど不倫なんかはしない
でも他のところでもうすぐ依存しちゃうんです
音楽になったらもう依存症になっちゃう
だからそれも悪いんだと
だからやっぱりバランスを取った社会をできてほしい
音楽もあって 芸術もあって
美味しい食べ物もあって
もうそういう全部あっていいんですけど
そこら辺でどこかで我々はいくらかコントロールしないと
ちょっと危ないんじゃないかと
それはもう私が言ったって
私の説明には経典から出す引用がないんですね
だから教授はもう変遷認めない
認めなくたってもそれはしょうがないんだけどね
ですからこの それもはっきりわかりませんだけど
とにかくね 要は私個人の解釈っていうのは
現身離世心を楽しむこと
ちょっと量を考えて 決まりを考えて
程よくやった方がいいということなんですね
そこを乗り越えちゃったら罪だよと
リミット破っちゃったらダメよと
そちらでもリミットがある
それから 4番目何でしたっけ？それだけですね
その 4つ 殺生すること
盗むこと 密 それからこの欲に間違っている行動
体でするんだと それは正真正銘の体の行為なんです
でも心が出なければできませんよ
それで言葉の行動は 4つあります
えっと 妄言ですか 妄言
離間語 わからない 離間語と粗悪語
綺語 全部綺語みたいな言葉ですからわからないんですけど
で 1番目はむさわーだ
嘘を言うこと  2番目はパルサーワーチャ
ピスナーワーチャ これはこの噂ですね
なんで噂は離間語になってるんですかね
この 2番目 この離間語と書いてますけど
私そのもう間が離れているっていう意味はわかりませんだけど
で まあその意味だったらその意味なんです
いわゆる人間の調和 お互いに仲良くしていることを破る意味
気持ちで喋ること 事実喋ったってのはダメなんです
例えば ある人がある人の悪口を言ったと
それで私はその人に「あんた知ってますか？あの人はあなたの悪口言ってるんですよ」と
そのまま報告する 嘘言ってるわけじゃないんです
それは罪なんです だって私は嘘をついてるな
言ってませんよと言って開き直ったっても罪を犯している
どういう罪かというと
その二人の間がそれで割れちゃうんですね
ですから 人と人が仲良くするのは素晴らしいことだと仏教で考えてるんです
人間は喧嘩するべきではない
誰であろうがお互いに仲良くしなくちゃいけない
だから慈悲との概念だから
動物とも調和を持って生活しなくちゃいけない
それで誰と何か仲が悪くなることしたら
それはどうせ罪になっちゃう
人間の間では言葉でそれがうまくできるんです
だから人の悪口 その人がないところで喋ろうと
喋ったっても それで間が悪くならなきゃ別に問題ないんだけど
とにかく人の悪口言いたければ面と向かって言った方がいいんです
その人悪いんだからね
それくらい自信がないんですね
だから弱くて 私は言います
悪いと見たならば もう一応言ってはいましたけど
それまたあまりいい結果でもないですから
まあもう黙っているし
でないところで言うのは簡単ですけどね
それで何の結果もないしね
とにかくその人は話聞くなと
直せる可能性あるんだったらいい嘛
それでそうでないと もうまあどうにどうに自由に勝手に自由に勝手にやってくださいと
この無関心な態度を取ります
余計なことに何かね 口を出して余計なトラブルを作る必要はない
悪いのは他人なのに なんでそこまで私までそれに巻き込まれる必要がありますかということで
とにかくこの人間っていうのは
互いに仲良くするために言葉を喋るんであって
仲が悪くなるのは喋ってはいけない
次にやるのはパルサーチャーでしょうね
そう悪語 パルサーチャー
パルサーチャー それは人をけなす言葉なんですね
人のプライドを傷つく言葉
その場合は直接喋るんです
ですから 言葉はちょっと熱量なんです
で 人が話を聞いた人がすごく自分の態度傷つけちゃって
すごい気持ち悪くなって悲しくなったりという
そういう言葉を喋ったりで悩んだりする
で みんな平気で言葉を喋る
コントしない そこをやめた方がよろしい
次にあるのは無駄話 ただ喋ると
それで時間がなくなる
大事な時間が それでお互いにこの喋ることに酔っちゃうんですね
ということは 頭がすごい混乱状態にあるということ
よく喋る人々は結構混乱なんです
だから喋るんだったら意味のあることを喋ると頭は整理するんです
何でもいいんだから喋る人はもう頭は混乱しているんです
その 4つ そこで心の罪っていうのは
1番目Avijjā Avijjā
っていうのは この何て言いますか
異常な欲 こっち貪欲と書いてますけど
異常な欲と覚えておいてください
ちょっと異常だと欲は
なぜならば欲は普通にもあります Avijjā
というのは異常なんです
普通の欲でそんなに罪は犯せません
ちょっと欲が異常  2番目怒りなんですけど
それも異常 だから病的な怒り
3番目は邪見 その 3つ
心の罪です じゃあそこで終了します
[背景音][背景音]